kein phantom autos nur eine
geschicklichkeit schulung für den
künftigen fahrlehrer er muss den
kritischen situationen auch wenn er
nicht neben dem park wieder sitzt
eingreifen können
das bundesheer als größter
fahrzeughalter österreichs mit mehr als
11.000 fahrzeugeinheiten ist bemüht
seinen fahrern bestmöglichste ausbildung
zu vermitteln
der fahrlehrer in uniform muss seinen
schülern in jeder hinsicht vorbild sein
um sich geschicklichkeit und ruhiges
besonnenes verhalten am steuer ergänzt
sein fachwissen auch die kraft voraus
bildung der militärakademie cup findet
in der heeres kraft schule statt
der österreichische offizier muss allen
aufgaben gewachsen seien wir an ihm im
rahmen des kraft verdienstes herantreten
die wartung des fahrzeuges und das
feststellen von schäden jeder
beherrschen diese kurse dienen vor allem
der perfektion der zukünftigen offiziere
pferdes fahrzeuge sind nicht nur auf
autobahnen oder hauptverkehrsstraßen
unterwegs militärische einsätze und
übungen kunden sehr oft im unwegsamen
gelände statt
hier muss sich der fahrer und die
solche festplatten gelten nicht allein
die ausbildung sie dienen auch der
technischen erprobung und
weiterentwicklung in fahrzeugen
der bub linger der in gemeinsamer arbeit
von perez technikern und heimischen
ingenieuren und arbeitern geschaffen
wurde ist heute weit über österreichs
grenzen bekannt und anerkannt und ein
guter export artikel die karts melder
unseres heeres haben eine bedeutende
funktion im truppendienst zu erfüllen
trotz aller technischen nachrichten
mittel ist er soldat in sattel einer
maschine nicht nur verlässlicher
nachrichten träger er ist auf die
verlängerte hand des kommandanten
dabei ist dem kein gelände zu schwierig
[Musik]